I'm in my car okay tears 30 minutes I'm
crying like a little baby okay 30
minutes some of you guys brag about
going to clubs Thursday and ladies night
Friday Saturday Sunday I was so
committed to x' day through Sunday you
know you're hardcore party if you go to
clubs on Tuesday night Thursday night is
a given Sunday if you're half committed
Tuesday you're fully committed I was
fully committed I'd go to Vegas 26 times
a year what club you want me to go to
pimps and hoes you want to go to Dre's
what do you want to go I was out all the
you know huh there's all this
stuff this is what we did I was
permanently banned from Dublin's because
of something that happened I could never
go back to Dublin's 22 years old that's
who knows Dublin's anybody knows
Dublin's I can never go to Dublin's
against I was permanently banned so this
isn't the Patrick you know today was a
complete different guy that night in my
Ford Focus It was as if you I came the
next day I didn't see a single girl
nothing I saw through people people
thought I was pissed I'm not pissed
I fully got it my dad's not gonna work
at this 99-cent store ever again the Bay
David family all these people that would
say the David family all divorced
middle-eastern mom and dad got a divorce
poor bit David he's probably gonna be a
bad kid I hear he had a 1-point a GPA
he's hanging out with gangsters and he
went to the army because that's the only
Saviour yet I said my family I said let
me simplify something for you guys
listen
I said the world's gonna know this last
name I know the pain we went through I
know the challenges we went through as a
family when we came to America from Iran
I saw your language barrier mom you were
so embarrassed I saw the look on your
face dad when you were so embarrassed
going to gatherings and you would look
like people like this to people because
you were so embarrassed I said you're
gonna be so proud of your last name
you're gonna be so proud you came to
America you're gonna be so proud of the
sacrifices you made that day I never
recognized all Patrick ever again
game over like this 180 no one
recognized me I got the best compliments
of all time which is Pat you've changed
we don't recognize you anymore we miss
the old Pat I said I have no desire to
spend time with the old Pat I'm in love
with the new path I don't care about the
old path and it shifted